Joe Biden and the Congress have spent
$7.5
billion on electrical vehicle charging
this started 2 years ago they they spent
$7.5 billion how many electric vehicle
Chargers do you think have been built
now 2 years later with that 75 billion
you guessed it none whatsoever the 2021
infrastructure investment and jobs act
included 7 and a half Bill to build a
half million public charging stations
across the country under this program
states can qualify for as much as 80% of
the cost to build these Chargers and to
get them up and running 80% and still
none of them have been built the money's
gone but none of them have been built
Politico
reported not one single charger was
operational I think they only broke
ground on a handful of them